will thank you I'm very flattered I
never really expected to get that kind
of reaction to my tails
I don't want to have to hit you Nicki
snap out of it okay all right
you know we're here to present the award
for the best performance by an actor in
a supporting role and the nominees are
Albert Brooks in broadcast news Morgan
Freeman street-smart
Sean Connery Indian
Denzel Washington in cry freedom
it's a gardenia moonstruck
Sean Connery
good evening ladies and gentlemen
friends a few enemies I don't think
there's anyone aware or unaware rather
in Hollywood or the rest of the world
tonight that this is the 60th
anniversary of these Academy Awards and
I just realized myself the other day
that he my first one in only attendance
was 30 years ago
patience truly is a virtue
um but it in winning this award it
creates a certain dilemma because I had
decided if I had the good fortune to win
that I would give it to my wife who
deserves it but this evening I
discovered backstage that they're worth
$15,000 and
now I'm not so sure show you're only
kidding it's yours but if such a thing
is a wish accompanied this award mine
would be that we ended the right of
strike and I thank you all sincere